your face isn't symmetrical and that's
okay
this face really asymmetrical the
strawberry squid has one tiny eye and
one huge one this is actually a
brilliant adaptation to life in the deep
ocean because the strawberry squid is
hunting food both above and below it the
big eye looks up scanning for creatures
casting silhouettes against the dim blue
light filtering down from the surface
the itty-bitty eye points down hunting
for critters using bioluminescence to
communicate and speaking of
bioluminescence the strawberry squid has
a glowy trick of its own those pits that
make it look like a strawberry actually
emit light instead of deliciousness by
firing these up on his underside the
squid could match the light coming from
above
it's camouflage through and through
rendering the squid nearly invisible to
anything watching below the thing is the
critters prey often used the same
counter illumination as it's known but
notice here that the strawberry squids
giant eye closed yellow which isn't
troubling at all this is because it
absorbs more blue light if a preys
counter illumination is too green
compared to the blue light above it'll
stand out so there's no avoiding the
all-seeing eye of the deep it's kind of
like the Eye of Sauron except not made
of fire or pure evil
you